if you are a mobile for an extended
period of time because of surgery
pregnancy illness or travel you may be
at risk for deep vein thrombosis or DVT
a condition where a blood clot forms in
a deep vein in the body typically the
leg
unlike arteries which rely on the heart
to force blood through them veins
transport blood with the help of muscle
contractions while you move and walk
veins also have valves that keep blood
from flowing backward and pooling in
your arms and legs when you are a mobile
for an extended period your venous
circulation slows down
as a result clotting factors in the
blood may cause the slow-moving blood to
clump together forming a blood clot or
thrombus
this condition is called deep vein
thrombosis or DVT
common symptoms of DVT include swelling
of the leg or a vein in the leg pain or
tenderness in the area increased warmth
in the skin and red or discolored skin
in some DVT cases a blood clot may
detach from a deep vein and join the
bloodstream the clot travels from the
deep veins of the leg through the veins
of the abdomen into the heart and
finally lodges in the pulmonary artery
or its branches blocking blood flow to
the lungs this condition called
pulmonary embolism is very serious and
may permanently damage a portion of the
lung if a clot is large or if there are
many clots pulmonary embolism may also
cause death
if you experience symptoms of PE please
tell your doctor or nurse immediately
these symptoms may include shortness of
breath a sudden sharp pain in the chest
a feeling of lightheadedness or
dizziness rapid or irregular heartbeat
or coughing that produces blood
to help prevent deep vein thrombosis and
pulmonary embolism
your doctor may require you to do the
following walk around periodically to
keep the blood from pooling in your legs
wear compression stockings and take
anti-clotting medication